r des panamas peppers est ce que vous
êtes indignés par les révélations sur
les circuits sombre de l'argent offshore
et les implications de personnalités y
compris politiques côté tout le monde se
douter de l'existence des ces sociétés
écrans je crois que personne n'avait
pris tout à fait conscience de l'ampleur
du problème
je vais confier quand vous êtes ministre
de l'intérieur à arnaud montebourg et à
vincent peillon
une mission d'étude et un rapport qu'ils
m'ont remis sur les circuits de
blanchiment de l'argent sale et par
conséquent cela les avait amenés à une
tournée mondiale et un rap à me remettre
un rapport à remettre au gouvernement un
rapport qui était très intéressant alors
il y avait des propositions notamment la
transmission automatique des données
d'état à état pur et dur allemand
réprimer la fraude fiscale je me réjouis
de tout ce qui va dans le sens de la
transparence
je me réjouis aussi que la justice
française a ouvert une enquête
très vite plusieurs chef de l'état l'a
annoncée quelques heures après les
premières révélations souhaitable cela
dit je suis un peu circonspect
c'est un peu circonspect sur l'origine
de ces fuites massives 11 millions et
demi de documents ce n'est pas à la
portée d'un vulgaire à coeur 1 il faut
que des services spécialisés chez soi
mis au travail à un parler de services
spécialisés bastien a oui comme le
kremlin puisque je vais vous donner la
réaction est fière du kremlin ou à
propos de poutine pour cause du moins à
travers ce non mais écoutez écoutez
écoutez voilà ce qu'on dit au kremlin
parce que je trouve avelar des
rapprochements ram est très très rapide
et voilà hier nous connaissons bien
cette soi disant communauté
journalistique il ya parmi eux de
nombreux journalistes dont le
journalisme n'est pas l'activité
principale
beaucoup sont d'anciens employés du
département d'état de passer à d'autres
services secrets alors vous aussi vous
évoquez des services à moi je n'ai pas à
désigner
le service qui est à l'origine je vous
ai dit que probablement ça n'était pas à
la portée d'un vulgaire à coeur et je
répète mon propos qu'il fallait des
services spécialisés pour opérer la
collecte de données qui pourraient
remplir 700 fois la bible oui oui c'est
un mais quand on vous dit c'est un
consortium de journaux internationaux
une queue d'une centaine cela fait cinq
ans d'un bon il y a
les données les mêmes qui leur sont
transmises
et puis il ya le travail que font ces
journalistes à partir quand même d'une
certaine sélection des cibles car il
faut des mots clés pour faire travailler
les ordinateurs et puis procéder à un
certain nombre de regroupements est ce
que vous êtes étonnés de l'absence par
exemple d'américains dans la liste des
personnalités question qu'on ne peut que
se poser
vous vous la poser oui on sait que tous
les parlementaires français et tous les
parlementaires européens ont fait
l'objet d'une enquête par le tue à
partir de leur nom
jean pierre je vais donc s'il ya quand
même une indignation voulant temps en
temps on n'entend pas tellement mais je
suis aussi et on défend et on défend
tous les hadjis glados
mais il ya très longtemps que je suis
indignée ah oui parce que je sais à la
différence de beaucoup qui semblent le
découvrir que c'est comme cela que ça
marche et que en effet les gens qui
disposent des moyens financiers
colossaux comme nous le savons 1 1% de
la planète détient une fortune
comparable aux 99 cents restons mais on
sait qu'actuellement il s'est alors pour
vivre heureux évoqué vivons cachés ce
n'est pas une découverte
bien sûr c'était un axiome d'un
industriel pensez vous évoquez bon
le rôle de certains services alors que
certains dans cette affaire est
d'ailleurs la plupart des gens défendent
le rôle des lanceurs d'alerté
vous êtes sceptique vous êtes parlant
sur une alerte par hasard je vais pour
pouvoir lancer une alerte faut avoir
accès à des données extrêmement vaste
alors ça sert qui alors que selon vous
c'est je suis votre réflexion et vous
savez j'ai regardé attentivement ce qui
était dit dans les colonnes du journal
le monde
plus lire qu'il ya beaucoup
d'approximations on nous parle d'une
station de ski avec cette piste à une
heure de route de saint pétersbourg
alors moi je voulais un peu la russie
effectivement puisque j'ai une mission
sur ce rallye c'est très plat vous savez
au tour de saint pétersbourg je ne vois
pas où peut-être cette station de ski
j'ajoute que ce sont des proches se sont
pas les dirigeants qui sont nommément
mis en cause ce sont des proches
quel lien on peut le supposer on le
découvre pas que l'urss a disparu que la
russie est un pays capitaliste que les
gens qui sont désignés comme étant les
oligarques la nouvelle bourgeoisie
ce sont des gens qui ont fait main basse
sur les richesses qui était celle de
l'union soviétique jadis donc voilà on
ne tombe pas quand même on ne fait pas
comme si on tombait du ciel
la république est elle en danger selon
vous face à la montée du salafisme qui
est en train de remporter une victoire
selon manuel valls alors il faut
toujours être très précis dans ces
domaines d'abord notre ennemi c'est le
terrorisme djihadiste le salafisme
c'était une certaine lecture du coran et
des textes sacrés une lecture
littéraliste c'est une lecture telle
qu'on pouvait l'opérer au septième
siècle au moment de l'hégire et par
conséquent cette lecture était peut-être
concevable dans le haut moyen-âge
mais aujourd'hui ne l'est pas car il
faut pas oublier que dans le coran aussi
il y à l'appel
quarante quatre fois à la raison
naturelle il y a le label à s'approprier
le savoir en allant jusqu'en chine
c'est à dire aux extrémités du monde
connu à l'époque donc le coran peut être
lu dans un esprit tout à fait différent
et je pense que le salafisme n'est pas
non plus le djihadisme
il y as salafisme qui est dit quiétiste
mais on sait d'expérience que le
salafisme peut aussi générer des
mouvements qui a dit stop autant
ciellement terroristes et ce que dit
manuel valls est tout à fait juste
s'agissant de l'implantation de réseaux
salafistes de mosquées salafistes puis
entendu 1%
c'est un peu plus à ma connaissance
c'est peut-être plus près de 10 % 10 %
on parle d'une centaine de mosquées leur
avis mais et de son influence
on l'a entendu notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux mais qu'est ce qui vous choque
le plus aujourd'hui dans certaines
revendications ou provocation tous pour
vos questions que vous pouvez regarder
autour de vous en ce qui concerne par
exemple de la laïcité qui est un combat
qui vous est cher jean pierre
chevènement
oui alors je pense que la laïcité est
mal comprise et les souvent défigurent
et elle n'est pas tournées contre la
religion
elle distingue simplement l'espace de la
religion qui appartient à chacun et
l'espace public
l'espace commun où les citoyens doivent
débattre c'est le débat républicain
ils doivent se déterminer sur ce qu'est
l'intérêt général et ils doivent le
faire à la lumière de la raison
naturelle qui je le rappelle est
mentionné 44 fois par le prophète jean
jacques berque dans la traduction qui a
donné du corps est ce que je n'ai pas
l'impression aujourd'hui que les
adversaires de la laïcité retrouve de la
voix et un certain écho dans notre pays
et je pense qu'il ya une grande
incompréhension
oui en france même de la part de
certains de nos concitoyens de ce que
signifie la laïcité
la laïcité c'est une exigence c'est une
exigence de dépassement ça veut dire que
l'on cherche en soi même les arguments
qui peuvent convaincre l'autre on ne
cherche pas à imposer imposer sa
croyance et par conséquent pour les
musulmans ça demande un effort
oui un toulouse demandé de faire je
pense que c'était fort il a fallu le
demandé aux catholiques aux juifs aux
protestants faut le demander aussi aux
musulmans
cela veut dire que dans l'espace public
on ne s'affirme pas part je dirais des
codes vestimentaires capillaires ou par
des affirmations religieuse dont chacun
est libre de les accepter pour ce qui le
concerne
mais ça n'a rien à voir dans le débat
public
françois hollande est le président
légitime de tout le français puisqu'il a
été élu bon wagon
donc je suis légitimiste il faut qu'il
aille au terme de son mandat faut-il
qu'ils se représenter en 2017
c'est à lui de le dire il a laissé
entendre que peut-être il ne se
représenterait pas s'il ne parvenait pas
à inverser la courbe il y en même temps
plus généralement on le voit prendre des
initiatives comme par exemple la loi
elle conneries qu'ils ne vont pas dans
le sens de sa réélection si il l'a
souhaité est donc on peut penser que il
a une certaine distance à l'égard de cet
évènement qu'est maintenant à l'horizon
alors si ce n'est pas mais comme s'ils
se sacrifier en quelque sorte et je me
suis mis à écouter on n'a pas de raison
de faire un procès d'intention à
françois hollande il est sincère c'est
un disciple de jacques delors 1
il croit au choix qui ont été faits il y
a une trentaine d'années il persévère
dans ses choix
il accepte finalement quelque chose qui
est assez dure c'est à dire une
discipline budgétaire ou bien des lois
de flexibilité comme la loi l comrie qui
lui sont plus ou moins dit qu'elle se
recadre elle-même européenne sur quelles
promesses pourrait-il l'emporter en 2017
et bien aujourd'hui je le vois pas on
lui reproche beaucoup n'aiment pas avoir
tenu les promesses qu'il avait faites en
2002 mais parce qu'il voulait être
cohérent avec ce qu'ils étaient ces
choix profond mais c'est le choix
profond n'était pas cohérent avec le
discours qu'il a prononcé au beau jeu
la gauche part extrêmement dispersé
alors déjà à l'heure actuelle pour
l'élection présidentielle
est-ce que après le souvenir notamment
de 2002 de lionel jospin qui était donc
arrivé troisième à l'issue du premier
tour à la présidentielle
vous pensez pas qu'il ya un risque et il
ya notamment un risque front national
mais les raisons pour lesquelles ça
pourrait se produire aujourd'hui sont
les mêmes pour lesquels cela s'est
produit en 2002 mais aggravées ce que le
pen on voulait venir depuis 1983 84
ça n'a pas été une découverte en 2002 ce
qu'ils ont fait sans bornes se réveiller
à l'époque se sont aussitôt réant dormi
et je dirais que françois hollande était
quand même premiers secrétaires du parti
socialiste il n'a conservé
je dirais dans une situation totalement
et mobile en 2005 le parti socialiste
s'est présenté pour le traité
constitutionnel européen
il a été battu dans les urnes 45% ça n'a
pas empêché le traité de lisbonne 3 ans
plus tard qui a été adopté par le
congrès à la majorité des trois
cinquièmes avec l'accord du parti
socialiste à l'époque dirigée par
françois hollande et du président de la
république qui était à ce moment là donc
là ça risque de dispersion vous à nous
verrons bien la décision que prendra
françois hollande moi je lui reconnais
la liberté de décider et je ne pense pas
qu'ils doivent se soumettre
s'il décide d'être à nouveau candidat à
des primaires je ne comprends même pas
comment un président de la république en
exercice pourrait se soumettre à des
primaires
enfin l'or les diamants à sa demande que
le parti socialiste modifier ses statuts
alors à titre personnel daniel cohn
bendit juge aujourd'hui que ces
primaires de la gauche et des
écologistes qu'il avait lancé on s'en
souvient avec d'autres ne sont plus
possibles décéléré une girouette c'est
une girouette un salaire et mesures
prendre a ajouté daniel bas d'il ya
trois mois était jour des primaires
aujourd'hui il est contre un à quoi ça
ressemble il faut avoir quand même ils
seraient de continuité licra la vie
politique si les trois mois cas au bout
de trois mois
voilà ce qu'ils vivent dans le monde ce
soir jean pierre chevènement vous et ce
n est pas la bible
je vais vous sentez droit des choses
sérieuses je verrai je vais vous avez
des leclerc girouette puisque vous
l'appeler comme ça des nefs cohn bendit
après avoir lancé des appels sur la
primaire il déclare il voulait qu'il
voulait sortir du marasme dans lequel
nous nous trouvons
il dit aujourd'hui donc ça n'est plus
possible c'est mon intime conviction
s'est bâti une nouvelle lubie
je lui dirais que c'est un amuseur et je
reconnais que c'était une mesure de
talent mais traiter le portel
est-ce que l'accord signé entre la
turquie et l'union européenne et il a
bon d'accord il a été négocié par un
merkel le conseil européen a entériné
c'est la loi du consensus c'est à dire
que très souvent l'allemagne prend des
décisions pour le compte des autres elle
est en position décisionnaires en europe
si c'était pour le bien de l'europe mais
est-ce que cet accord est applicable
ils m'aiment et puis ce matin ah ben il
est appliqué pour 200 migrants
il faudrait qu'ils appliquent pour la
grèce demandé une pause se souvient
davantage alors je ne sais pas moi je
mets en doute sa faisabilité et sa
conformité au droit international c'est
ce que vient de dire monsieur b you 1
je m'interroge mais en même temps je
pense qu'il faut négocier que la turquie
et la turquie est un grand payés
normalement nous devons tenir compte de
la turquie mais s'agissant de la syrie
je rappelle quand même que la turquie a
abrité dès 2011
l' armée syrienne libre c'est à dire que
au conflit entre le gouvernement de
damas et son opposition s'est surajouté
c'est sûr imposé hier sur la syrie est
en conflit
tombe par procuration est un petit peu
sur la turquie est ce que vous estimez
que c'est un pays sûr pour les réfugiés
mais je suis en train de vous expliquer
qu'il est partie prenante du conflit
syrien vous dites non donc est ce que
c'est un pays sûr on voit que malgré
tout il est exposé à un certain nombre
de chocs d'attentât et c'est que il est
divisé depuis que les négociations avec
le pkk c'est à dire avec les kurdes ont
été rompues alors pas requis par
monsieur erdogan parler parler kurde eux
mêmes c'est à voir mais disons que c'est
quand même un pays développés maintenant
à payer qui a les caractéristiques d'un
pays relativement sûr si on le compare à
beaucoup d'autres
virons il est moins sûr que que parce
qu'on n'ose plus dire la france 1 mais
parce que la france n'est plus tellement
un pays sûr pour ses concitoyens
vous pensez que la france n'est plus un
pays sûr pour ses concitoyens mais côté
un pays qui est exposé à des attentes à
répétition et à payer en insécurité
bien évidemment
vous avez fait estrade commune avec
nicolas dupont aignan à l'été dernier
vous pourriez dans un avenir proche et
j'en ai fait avec philippe séguin
d'autres temps et là la question comment
michael pense a sans doute le prendre
quand on vous entend parler de la
monnaie commune dans votre nouvelle
configuration on pense aussi aux
propositions faites marais d'opale m non
mais permettez moi de dire que c'est
moreno qui est le premier avancé cette
idée enfin guerrera très longtemps avec
solennité partagé par monsieur balladur
par monsieur bérégovoy c'est à dire dans
les années 1900 la fin des années 1970
donc là où je revendique un privilège
d'antériorité vous défendez les mêmes
idées mais non je ne te font pas les
mêmes idées quand le soleil brille à
midi le fait de le constater ne signifie
pas que vous mêmes idées que ceux qui le
croient simplement un constat c'est une
solution que vous partagez avec si vous
laissez le bon sens et que pour tenir
compte de la diversité de
l'hétérogénéité des pays européens
il faut que la menait plus puissent
fluctué nous sommes dans un monde
fluctuant
c'est ce qu'on appelle la globalisation
est donc il faut trouver des marges de
souplesse si vous voulez imposer un
carcan trop rigide à l'europe
vous avez ce que vous constatez tiers
une stagnation économique de longue
durée
une production industrielle qui décline
est aujourd'hui à 15 % en dessous de ce
qu'elle était en france en 2008 et un
chômage qui va toujours croissant de
tous alors si on veut enfermer la vie
politique d'un des anathèmes à vous
pensez comme le front national
tout artiste c'est l'avis de la
complètement le débat de toute
rationalité
je pense qu'il faut au contraire un
revenir à l'aller par sédition veut
républicains disent que le projet
économique n'est pas viable de la part
du front national vous vous ne partagez
pas cet avis je pense qu'ils sont pas du
tout équipés pour le mettre en oeuvre
et moi je propose une négociation avec
l'allemagne je n'ai pas du tout la même
vision que le front national
je ne dis pas que ça peut se faire du
jour au lendemain je pense que ça
demande une certaine maturation mais je
pensais dans cette
réaction là qu'il faut aller si nous
voulons rendre l'europe vivable pour
séparer les cas on retient quand même
que vous estimez que c'est logique
marine le pen a raison de vous rejoindre
sur les positions que vous avez en
commun
donc vous êtes mais marine m'appelle
dray aurait comme tout le monde
intérêt à me rejoindre quand j'ai raison
1 mais vous aussi vous auriez intérêt à
montjoie donc je répète ma question
l'alliance des souverainistes donc qui
ré de nicolas dupont aignan à marine le
pen fait à vous-même serait aujourd'hui
envisageable je pense qu'elle doit aller
beaucoup plus loin et je m'adresse
également aux socialistes
je m'adresse également aux républicains
de l'autre rive comme je lé fais en 2002
je pense que les celui triennaux par
exemple pense que les solutions oui que
j'ai invités n'y a pas très longtemps
dans une réunion de république moderne
aux côtés d'arnaud montebourg
eh bien je pense que en effet la
solution c'est de le c'est une solution
de rassemblement continuer à réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag pp3
tv